[Musica]
nel profondo del nostro cervello in una
parte profonda nell'ipotalamo
sono presenti due piccoli nuclei
formati da circa 20.000 neuroni che
rappresentano la sede anatomica del
nostro orologio circadiano Che cos'è
questo orologio circadiano è un insieme
di geni e di proteine che possiamo
chiamare geni e proteine orologio molti
che all'interno di questi neuroni
interagiscono tra loro in modo piuttosto
complesso
per generare una ritmicità
molecolare
che
in qualche modo si mantiene anche in
assenza di stimoli diversi è una
periodicità che accompagna la nostra
vita dalla nascita alla morte e questi
neuroni e questi queste oscillazioni
dettano il tempo al nostro organismo e
regolano la nostra fisiologia i nostri
comportamenti Nel corso delle nostre
giornate
e questi orologi rappresentano un
adattamento evolutivo
ai cicli alle variazioni cicliche
dell'ambiente provocate dalla rotazione
della Terra attorno al proprio asse
e
si chiamano
orologi circadiani da circa Diem Perché
in assenza di stimoli ambientali e
questi orologi
completano questi cicli molecolari
queste oscillazioni che ho menzionato
in circa 24 ore non in 24 ore ma nel
mondo reale Questo ad esempio
questi orologi
vengono sincronizzati quotidianamente
continuamente da fattori da segnali
provenienti dall'ambiente esterno che ci
mettono in armonia con i tempo della
rotazione terrestre ovvero 24 Ore
tutti gli organismi di essere viventi
hanno un orologio circadiano dai batteri
e i funghi alle piante agli animali ma
oggi parliamo del nostro quello dei
mammiferi e questo orologio
è
localizzato nel cervello e da una
funzione gerarchica di controllo su
tutta un'altra serie di orologi che
chiamiamo orologi periferici e che sono
localizzati in periferia per l'appunto
in molti organi in molti dei nostri
tessuti e questi orologi periferici sono
estremamente importanti perché pur sotto
il controllo dell'orologio del cervello
regolano modulano in periferia in
maniera fine precisa attività
fisiologiche e biochimiche proprie di
quell'organo del fegato piuttosto che
dei reni o
del cuore o dei polmoni regolando quindi
localmente certe attività che non sono
necessarie da altre parti
e ho fatto allusione al fatto che
questo orologio circadiano
regola molti delle nostre attività dei
nostri comportamenti compresi i ritmi
sonno veglia per esempio le nostre
abitudini sono Veglia
e c'è molta variabilità in queste
abitudini come per il colore degli occhi
o per il gruppo sanguigno anche per
quanto riguarda i ritmi sonno veglia
esistono individui che geneticamente e
sono più propensi a collocare la
porzione del sonno presto nel nella sera
o piuttosto tardi quindi esistono
individui che sono geneticamente
mattinieri o Quindi dell'allodole o
geneticamente serotini e quindi dei gufi
come come vengono anche chiamati e
questo dovuto al fatto che c'è una certa
variabilità genetica nella popolazione
ognuno di noi è un insieme di varianti
genetiche che si traducono in queste e
poi
propensioni a collocare il sonno presto
o tardi ovviamente in periodi intermedi
ma una componente genetica molto
importante in questo ed è un carattere
ed è un li chiamiamo cronotipi ed è un
comportamento che nel nostro e nella
nostra vita quotidiana faremo bene a ad
assecondare e non a contrastare come
molti di noi fanno
la luce quindi sincronizza il nostro
orologio circadiano
tramite l'occhio adesso vedremo come e
lo sincronizza e lo mette in armonia con
la rotazione terrestre E questo ci
garantisce una fisiologia una
modulazione della nostra fisiologia che
ci rende adatti via via
nelle varie ore al trascorrere del tempo
nelle nostre giornate Ma come viene
sincronizzato il loro orologio è un
processo molto complicato ci sono delle
cellule nella retina profonda qui è
quella rossa Se volete
identificarla In questa immagine queste
cellule gangliari non hanno niente a che
vedere o poco a che vedere con le
cellule implicate nella visione nei
processi visivi Nella formazione
dell'immagine Tuttavia sono cellule
fotosensibili anche queste cellule
percepiscono la luce in particolare la
componente blu dello spettro e
trasferiscono realtà
questa segnalazione questo segnale
vengono attivate e trasferiscono queste
informazioni direttamente
ai neuroni orologio situati come ho
detto nel nostro cervello nella parte
profonda del cervello
sincronizzando in questo modo
allineando in questo modo quella
ritmicità molecolare endogena con
l'orologio solare con il tempo solare
l'orologio solare del posto in cui
viviamo e sottolineo questo del posto in
cui viviamo perché è molto importante
Tra poco lo capiremo quindi
questo allineamento tra orologio
circadiano e orologio solare del posto
in cui viviamo è molto importante E
quando questo allineamento viene a
mancare come ad esempio quando ci
troviamo di fronte a lunghi viaggi in
cui Attraversiamo molti meridiani e
quindi proviamo malessere ci accorgiamo
che effettivamente il nostro organismo
Ne soffre perché c'è un disallineamento
tra orologio circadiano e l'orologio
solare del posto in cui arriviamo ci
vuole del tempo poi per rimediare a
questo danno ci vogliono giorni dipende
poi dalle distanze coperte e questa è la
ragione perché non siamo allineati con
il tempo con l'orologio locale ma
ma il
jet lag che molti di voi avranno provato
è una cosa un po' sporadica non è che
per molti di noi sia una consuetudine
quotidiana o frequente Ma nella nostra
società nella società industrializzata
molte persone soffrono di
disallineamento tra orologi circadiano e
orologio solare basti pensare per
esempio ai lavoratori ai turnisti quelli
che lavorano a turno nelle Industrie e
nell'ospedale
ma anche quelli che lavorano
sistematicamente di notte sono
disallineati e anche l'adozione dell'ora
legale rappresenta
una come dire un vulnus nei confronti di
un buon allineamento tra orologio
circadiano e ambiente nel quale viviamo
perché per tutto il tempo in cui viene
adottata Adesso per esempio per sette
mesi all'anno e come se noi facessimo
finta di vivere in un fuso orario Più
adesso del nostro ad Istanbul per
esempio è tuttavia il nostro orologio
circadiano ogni giorno viene
sincronizzato dalle Albe E dai Tramonti
di Castelfranco Veneto se siamo qui cioè
del posto in cui viviamo Quindi questa
adozione ci costringe
a Come dire ad accumulare del
malessere dovuto a questo
jet lag sociale Come viene chiamato e
per finire anche altre cattive abitudini
che molti di noi hanno contribuiscono a
disallineare il nostro orologio
circadiano dall'orologio solare ad
esempio l'esporsi Alla luce artificiale
di sera o di notte perché leggiamo il
tablet il computer o usiamo il
telefonino eccetera in particolare
esponendosi alla componente blu della
luce e ci induce a ritardare nella notte
L'inizio del nostro sonno e ad
accumulare
deprivazione di sonno e se questa
deprivazione di sonno è dura lungo nella
nostra vita si cronicizza o dura per
periodi importanti della nostra vita non
c'è dubbio Oramai che questo aumenta il
rischio per chi si espone a queste a
questi regimi di vita di
incorrere di in malattie e come la
sindrome metabolica malattie
cardiocircolatorie anche alcuni tumori
al colon e nelle donne del tumore al
seno
per esempio quindi
vivere in contrasto con il nostro
orologio circa diano e con i ritmi che
detta al nostro organismo e deleterio
per la nostra salute questo ormai è
accertato è una ricetta semplice per
aumentare il nostro benessere e per
avere una vita più sana e dunque quello
di è quella di vivere in armonia di
assecondare questa ritmicità endogena di
esporci Alla luce di giorno in
particolare al mattino ed ovviamente di
evitare il più possibile di esporsi Alla
luce di sera e di notte grazie
[Applauso]